Oh what is going home you two now about
a couple videos ago I did a video called
get over her and because of that y'all
asked for another video called
get over him and of course I can't speak
on behalf of women because obviously I'm
not a woman don't make a joke but I'm
more serious than the woman that I'm not
into go ahead to talk to y'all because
of her infinite wisdom is geo from just
kidding films now before you go ahead
and ask this question because I ever
know that you are I do not know what her
ethnicity is I have asked the countless
talk that she has not told me and I'm
her friend so just like you I'm letting
the dark so why don't we go ahead and
guess what she is geo means earth right
I'm finet Sam sounds French is hair
that's next French ass day my little
place home she's an avatar I don't know
anyway let's let's go and hear what you
have to say about this topic hey what's
up beautiful people with Ravana in here
and I'm going to be your big sister
today I'm going to give you some words
of advice but a quick disclaimer I'm not
going to sugarcoat [ __ ] and you're
probably going to hate me just saying
like you need to know that you are
valuable you're beautiful and you need
to have this confidence so let's go step
number one so as females we love to talk
amongst other females you know we're
kind of social butterflies we always
have to hang out with our ride-or-die
chicks but let me stop you there you
never want to ask your girlfriend that
is hella party animal hella Brody about
breakup advice because as soon as you
tell her he broke up with me Megan dude
this [ __ ] is gonna be on like gotta go
to Vegas groan I doubt this [ __ ] make
bad decisions yeah it's gonna be fun
while you're doing it but guess what you
got to wake up you're gonna be so
regretful of all the dumb [ __ ] you did
last night
also never talk to that enabling ass
girlfriend and
always like [ __ ] him he didn't deserve
you you are a goddess he is so lucky
that he even got with you she's gonna be
the one that's offering you a [ __ ]
big pint of ice cream you all are gonna
be sitting there getting [ __ ] fatter
and more miserable and guess what
nothing got soft so don't talk to that
[ __ ] it's gonna make you fat just say I
love you all those friends we always
need them in our life but you guys
thought Phineas [ __ ] ice cream step
number two you need to start thinking
about all the ex-boyfriend patterns you
need to start thinking about all the
guys that you're dating and why those
relationships didn't work us as females
we always make this huge mistake that we
can save the world we think we're
[ __ ] a wizard and [ __ ] so we always
feel like our love is so strong that
it's going to change him like I said
you're not a frickin magician you're not
a wizard so you can't change anything
that does not want to be changed yes I
know you're hurting right now but it's
really really really important that you
go out for the sake of going out and
let's say hey you're out in one of these
casual hanging out nights and you happen
to find a dude that's actually pretty
interesting this is not the time for you
to begin venting to this new dude about
your ex dude I was a dude and you're
talking to me about your ex-boyfriend
first of all I think you're [ __ ] hot
mess and you just need to get your life
together
second of all men I find you interesting
I'm trying to get to know you I'm not
trying to get to know your baggage like
for real like stop telling me this [ __ ]
cuz I don't give a [ __ ] cause you never
want to be so stuck in the past when the
time comes
have this diamond of a perfect dream
that in front of you that you're so
stuck in the past that you missed this
opportunity because you have this bitter
ash chip on your shoulder you know
that's pretty much the only advice I can
give you my beautiful females out there
stay strong stay positive um they're
always always is a tomorrow like people
say there's always a rainbow after rain
and [ __ ] or whatever
hakuna matata there's really hope I was
able to connect with you guys my
beautiful women um and and yeah good
luck in the dating world
I got you open like brackets in tennis
balls now put the camera down let me
take that off your ass in your brain
drop me
YouTube David you is one ugly female
okay had David the mic is on right okay
I don't know you kind of stupid
sometimes I'm just kidding